a complete degenerate by the name of
isaiah jackson
just photographed himself kneeling
on a two-year-old child's neck isaiah
jackson is a 20-year-old black guy
the child is a white two-year-old
wearing a diaper
being held down by another arm in the
photo we don't know
who that arm belongs to i think it
belongs to a woman
and he's shirtless he's throwing
some kind of sign down there child is
crying and it says
b-l-m now m-f
you look at this fight it's really a
heinous photo
fortunately this guy has been arrested
though he was arrested for a probation
violation
this you know this wonderful peaceful
demonstrator peaceful protester
ex-con degenerate who should never
ever ever be permitted out of prison at
least
at least never ever this guy
posts a photo as he is
violently attacking a two-year-old child
and in that photo he pretends to be the
victim
the photo which is very difficult to
look at is emblematic
of the whole damn culture
the violent aggressor pretends to be
the victim that's what's happening
that's what's happening right now
blm now mother effer as a two-year-old
child cries
fortunately in the case of this guy he's
been arrested and i hope he never sees
the light of day again
hope he hope he's gonna be in that
prison cell maybe i don't know maybe
ship him to gitmo or something i don't
know
no civil punishment could be too extreme
for this guy
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you